elon musk recently tweeted that he's
considering creating a new university
with a rude name texas institute of
technology and science this was most
likely his idea of a joke yet he's been
quite serious in his belief that today's
university degrees are useless you don't
need college learning learn stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free he feels the main value of college
is to test a student's resolve will they
finish their annoying assignment on time
rather than will they learn something
from it and then also you probably want
to hang around with a bunch of people
your own age for a while instead of
going right into the workforce so i
think colleges are basically for fun and
to prove you can do your chores but
they're not for learning legendary
silicon valley investor and paypal
co-founder peter thiel thinks you should
skip college altogether he offers a
fellowship of a hundred thousand dollars
for college students who drop out to
start their own companies what do we do
with universities what do you mean we
just try to get people out of them we
try to you know years ago i had this
fantasy of starting a new university
that would be sort of a better version
sort of a all-around good liberal arts
education with less political
correctness less you know thought
control teal believes higher education
is actually a form of brainwashing there
are still obvious perks of going to
university those with a bachelor's
degree still earned 500 more a week than
those who only graduated high school
according to the u.s bureau of labor
statistics however now there's a plan
that could topple the ivory tower google
made a huge announcement in the middle
of the pandemic it said it would beef up
its online school offering new courses
in data analytics project management and
user experience design created and
taught by google employees in the
related fields these courses are not
meant to supplement your university
degree but replace it
google senior vice president of public
affairs kent walker tweeted in our own
hiring we will now treat these new
career certificates as the equivalent of
a four-year degree for related roles
roles in high-growth high-paying fields
in which google says the average salary
is 63 000
a year walker wrote in a blog post that
college degrees are out of reach for
many americans as they struggle to pay
back student loans whereas google's
six-month courses cost 234 dollars the
price of just university textbooks
tuition in the u.s has ballooned over
the decades the cost of tuition fees
room and board at a four-year private
university in america is around 52 000
per academic year the vast majority of
the spending goes toward paying staff
and faculty according to the atlantic
despite having some of the most
expensive tuition in the world the u.s
lags far behind other developed nations
in math and technology skills more
necessary than ever as our jobs are
increasingly automated the oecd studied
the competency of adults around the
world surveying 245 000 people in 39
countries how did the u.s fare when it
comes to solving problems with digital
technology the u.s was an 18th spot
america fared worse when it comes to
math skills sitting in 27th place this
suggests a mismatch between what people
are currently taught at american schools
and what skills are actually required in
the real world tim cook certainly feels
that way the apple ceo thinks the one
skill every kid in the us should learn
before they graduate high school is
coding apple launched a program in 2016
designed to help students from
kindergarten to university learn to code
and also launched free coding courses
for teachers so they can pass on their
knowledge cook pointed out that in 2018
half of apple's american employees did
not have a four-year degree his
predecessor steve jobs famously dropped
out of reed college after just one
semester which i talked about in the
previous video that i'll link in the
description
jobs was one of many smart guys who
dropped out mark zuckerberg left harvard
during his sophomore year to work on
facebook full-time
bill gates quit harvard to focus on
microsoft daniel eck left his
engineering studies in sweden after just
eight weeks to co-found spotify elon
musk has expressed his admiration for
people who left school to start their
own companies in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something he is technically a dropout
himself leaving his phd program at
stanford after two days he's been vocal
about not requiring a university
education to work for him reaffirming it
when asked on twitter however it's
unclear how many people tesla has
actually hired without a university
degree i asked them but they didn't
respond tesla is looking to fill 10 000
jobs through 2022 for its gigafactory in
austin some still require a degree
others make no mention of one including
pretty good engineering jobs they do
require the ability to apply first
principles thinking to your
problem-solving approach first
principles is the practice of
questioning everyday assumptions for
example the assumption that batteries
for electric cars are expensive and
that's just the way it is first
principles involve rethinking what you
know which is what allowed tesla to
build cheaper battery packs musk applied
first principal's reasoning to question
how students should be taught when he
took his kids out of private school and
put them in a school he started in a
corner of spacex's factory this is video
from his at astra school provided to
newsthink the school which has since
closed after his boys graduated focused
on critical thinking skills and even had
a class on rocketry so many super
successful people believe there are
better ways to learn than in a
traditional classroom which brings me to
the sponsor of my video skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes you can learn the same
techniques that professional filmmakers
use to craft their videos you can learn
how to edit these videos there's
literally a class for everything you can
think of what's really great is that
it's for both beginners and those who
want to improve their skills the classes
are short and interesting and they're
broken down into different lessons so
you can easily navigate and choose what
you'd like to focus on the first 1000 of
my subscribers to click my custom link
in the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare
so you can start exploring your
creativity
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm